I've heard rumors around town that the
basement is known as a swingers hangout
and is used for late-night parties so
before dinner service I want to take a
look at what's downstairs my god some
really expensive stuff this is crazy
stop is here spending the money in all
the wrong places
oh my god please shout for entering the
mineral spa mineral spa oh my god that
was sweet
tonight is crucial because I need to get
my eyes on how Jonathan and Lisa are
running the hotel since both of them
seem to be on different pages there's so
much stuff in here I've never seen a
kitchen so cluttered it's been worse
believe it or not how come the food just
sits there right at the moment our
timing is really not at all good what
these four words on them those little
pre meals little cracked little piece of
cheese pre meals I got to the trash you
can't serve that there's a paper for
customers to eat you can't ask them to
dip into a [ __ ] doily for their
cracker and then a flowering and yum yum
yum yum it's just no it's bit [ __ ] up
Joey it's your place it's just a bit
weird you okay yeah no I'm fine I'm okay
one with the chickens roasted two days
ago that's the last of them
why do we roast them two days in advance
they're delivered twice a week they're
cooked up the delivery day what kind of
impression do you think you're sending
out to your customers when that chickens
roasted two days before they come where
do you think this chicken was roasted
you all goodness I hope it was today
it was roasted the toon half days ago
that was gonna be dry as a dog bone
but anyway try to enjoy 12 years you
need to seriously just focus on getting
this nut job and they sit there all
schmuck I want to kick them out right
now
do you want us to take the food bag I
mean this is like so disappointing that
you guys feel this way I thought we were
friends and I I thought you would maybe
told us if you felt the food sucked that
much you know it's really gosh I feel we
don't feel like I want to pass out right
now so the lady just talking to
everything have no idea how chicken
roasted to mark days ago it was roasted
two and half days ago yeah I didn't know
that okay it's not my business just
don't just eat you are so defensive
there's a thousand different ways to
make Spencer I'd like to do talk about
the chicane I'd love to find out the
project K and I'm told you about the
chicken
nothing resonates with you does it